in December the bodies of 71 soldiers
from nisha lay it a military base in the
capital near may a grim reflection of
growing violence in the soil they were
killed in an attack claimed by ISIL in
the west of the country I decided to
come myself to give my nation's
gratitude inconsolable but not all
defeated - these men plug from the
affection of their loved ones in the
prime of life for what they are to us
our heroes our martyrs the French
president Emmanuel macron visited me
share to pay his respects just three
weeks earlier in Paris makrand led a
memorial for 13 French soldiers killed
in a helicopter crash in Mali more than
4,000 French troops are fighting armed
groups in the soil alongside forces from
nisha bikina Faso Chad Mauritania and
Mali the g5 countries but as the
casualties mount so his hostility
against former colonial power France I
notice in too many countries an
anti-french sentiment is no prospering
without any clear political condemnation
I cannot accept sending our soldiers
into the field in countries where our
presence is not clearly requested the
French president has invited g5 leaders
to a summit to clarify whether they want
French troops to remain in their
countries their deployment isn't only
been questioned in the region though but
also here in France where the mission is
poorly understood by the public and
there's growing pressure on macro to
justify france's involvement this is
often filippov
for six years with operación botkin
france has been in the Sahel and it
seems we're at a tipping point there are
no real results people in Sahel aren't
positive about the situation the threat
hasn't been eradicated so the g5 Sahel
countries are asking themselves if
France is really the only country that
has solutions maybe other countries can
help people wonder if it's time to stop
increasing a French military presence
that is costly to Africans and France
Mike Ross says if French troops are to
continue fighting in Syal he wants a
greater commitment from g5 leaders he's
expected to achieve that for now but
what's less clear is for how long
Natasha Butler al Jazeera Paris